Hank how are you this morning I'm fine
dan how are you I'm doing okay when I
say the wind is blowing out at Wrigley
does that bring any memories back back
for you you think I don't know whether
yeah I think that even even with the
wind blowing out I think the pictures
would probably control the game in some
ways you know it's been a very good
series so far well when's the last time
you hit a home run
I'm sorry can I be get you when's the
last time you hit a ball out of the
ballpark
you know I don't remember I really don't
remember because I it's been a long time
since I picked up a bat you know I yeah
and then the other day I had the
privilege of throwing the last pitch at
the stadium in Turner's field and mom
got to a certain point
but growing up my wife got on with you
there you can't even throw it for have
away from home plate to do the kitchen
mice you know I can't it's going out Dan
it's it's it was there and it's not
there anymore you grew up you batted
cross-handed didn't you for a little
while I did I did in fact I was talking
to some friends of mine the other night
at the hall a minute the World Series
and they were bringing up the same thing
and I said you know it's a funny thing I
did that all through playing and the
Negro League and then when I got into
Professor ball at old Claire I started
playing hidden Beth left and it switches
and until the bat slipped out of my hand
and broke are you but you know this
fella named Wes Covington Young's nose
and the coach told me right then he said
I want you to stay on the right side
that's a good decision
what do you have memorabilia wise that
might surprise me from you
career from when I'm sorry from your
career what kind of memorabilia
you know balls bad I don't I don't have
anything I really don't you know I've
given everything I had to the Hall of
Fame
everything you know I I don't even have
a ring you know I've given everything in
fact they've been very kind to me and
I've given them everything and rings
watches everything and I don't even have
I think I got one watch and there were a
time when I had at least 45 or 50 I gave
them all I'll give it all to all of him
well if you could have one thing for
yourself on display at home what would
you want to put out there for people to
see it would have to be something in the
badan department I think I would have to
have a back 715 simple somewhere in that
order
also the bat you used for 715 yeah yeah
that would be that would be my logical
choice you know when you look at the the
homerun and what it means or what it
used to mean is it would you be a
different hitter now where remember it
was embarrassing if you struck out
anywhere near a hundred times now it's
almost like it's that's the Badge of
Courage here for hitters that you know
you're supposed to strike out a hundred
times so what how different you be now
you know I was talking to my friend you
know Willie Mays about about three weeks
or four weeks ago and I was telling him
I said Willie you know I said it you and
I played today I said yeah probably sent
us back to the minor leagues cuz we said
we didn't make enough we made too much
contact but I think that the motion if I
can answer you this way please
the most embarrassing things in it that
happens to me in my 23 years is walking
from home plate back to the dugout after
striking out know regardless of who's
pitching and we placed some very tough
pitches Koufax Gibson and
and all these hall-of-famers and I just
felt like it was very embarrassing for
me to strike out you know in aa date I
think I've seen hitters strike out and
go back to the dugout and almost
laughing about it yeah it just feels
like it's on a big deal to strike out
anymore but I understand what you're
saying like the worst feeling you could
ever have is I struck out I didn't help
my team didn't put the ball in play and
you know that that pitcher got the best
of me and that was my motto you know is
to do everything I could in fact after
talking to Jackie Robinson for for so
many years before he passed away he said
the best thing that you can do for your
team is go to the home plate now he put
it very simple he said go to home plate
and make sure that when you go to touch
home plate again and you have done
something to help your team and that's
the way I felt all of my 23 years I felt
like the bad knavish was good the home
runs were good but runs batted in was
even better and run scored was even
better than that he's Hank Aaron hold a
Famer joining us Dan Patrick show I
don't know how many years you uh I'm
trying to think this when Jackie
Robinson broke the color barrier how
many years after that before you got
your chance to play with the Milwaukee
Braves it was 19 was that 54 53 oh yeah
what's 54 that's right yes yes what do
you remember about Jackie Robinson with
what he went through and what he meant
to all the other players who came after
him well what I meant what I meant what
he meant to me you know I always would
pick his brains know no matter where
where he was or whether he was playing
with the Dodgers and had an off day I
would always go and sit and talk with
him and the things I remember him he
said he said the game of baseball is
great he said but the greatest thing is
what you do after you career is over
with what you do with it and that was
one of the thing that really stuck in my
mind for the 20-some years that I played
I played the game I was blessed enough
to play the game
for 23 years but the most important
thing I also tell it tell my wife this
the most important thing is that what I
can do for others once my career is over
with I was blessed because the good Lord
gave me the ability to play this game
but by the same token I have to be
blessed enough to understand I have two
half-brothers could you've done what
Jackie did you know I don't think so
and I said that and not knowing and
because he really went through an awful
lot you know and and and anybody said
that they could have taken what he did I
don't think they understood the things
that he went through I don't know that I
could have and to be honest with you I
had enough problems when I was chasing
the babes record you know and I know
that was just the tip of the iceberg
just what he went through did you save
any of those letters not not that you
you should or it's bad and horrible what
people wrote that did you save any of
those things that were sent to you I'd
say most of them oh yeah most of them
and the reason I saved them because I am
blessed now with five grandchildren one
is in Michigan and she's doing quite
well and I had one in Arizona he's done
quite well and I just want them to
understand that it wasn't long ago that
I to was to hinder racial discrimination
you know I mean so yes I saved quite a
few of them and they were terrible what
they wrote Hank they what they were very
bad they were very bad but you know the
thing that was so bad about him was the
fact that in all of the interviews that
the police and the detectives and
whoever was else in charge said that all
of these were just crank letters said
but it may be one in there that meant
something so you have to check them all
out did you realize that that was Craig
Sager who was at home plate in that
white trench coat after you hit the 715
home run oh yeah yeah Craig and I were
very good friends in fact one day you
need to talk to him and ask him about he
and I are going to Cuba made
many years ago interviewing those Cuban
ball players yes oh yeah I knew that was
Korea Craigslist I told a lot of him you
know he's a wonderful man
do you follow the Colin Kaepernick
protest with him kneeling on the
sidelines I do a little bit I do a
little bit and yet you know it you know
I don't put myself in that place
position I said that the only thing I
can say for him is that he'd know
exactly what he's done and I have to go
along with it so you understand it how
would that I mean obviously doing it
back in the 70s probably wouldn't our
60s wouldn't have gone over well but the
fact that he's doing it you don't have a
problem with it or you understand why
he's doing it I don't have a problem
with it Dan
it's him I don't have a problem with it
he knows what he's doing and I'm sure
that he's a grown man and he understands
what he's done
can you describe what the feeling is
like when you hit a home run for those
of us who will never get that
opportunity well I think that the
feeling that you get you hit in my case
of course I hit at 755 quite natural
when I hit the ball I knew it
each time I I was a I was a fly ball
hero you know as they say in baseball
and once I got the ball up in the air I
knew that I had a good chance of hitting
on the ballpark and it made me feel good
and I felt was that I don't know that
you feel in it particularly it in any
way different than you do when you get a
base hit to win the game you know I mean
all of those things of stick in your
mind a little bit you know sure I feel
good about it well I wondered it and
I've guys have told me that it's
effortless that you swing and it it just
it doesn't feel like you're doing
anything and when you hit it out of the
park
is that fair sense well and and and part
of that is true yes right and part of it
is truly I think that when you swing the
bat yeah I've always said when you make
contact with the ball you know ball is
kind
ninety miles an hour and you make
contact with a bat and you hit a
squirrel you hit it well enough usually
you have no feeling but it feels so good
you know once you hit it out of the
ballpark did you ever have a problem
that it was Willie Mickey in the Duke or
it was Willie and Mickey and you were
sort of left out of the bigger picture
or the national picture of great players
in the game you know I felt that way and
yet I looked at my position I said you
know I'm blessed I was blessed I was
blessed to have played all of my career
in Milwaukee Wisconsin
and I don't know coming from Mobile
Alabama a little country boy a little
black boy coming from Mobile Alabama
without a fit in good in New York City I
don't know that I really don't know so I
you know in some ways I was blessed
because I played it in Milwaukee we
didn't get to hike as they got it
Marilyn Mays and those guys in New York
got but by the same token we will very
loved we would love and I felt it and
being 19 years old it really made me
feel good because it was something that
I probably couldn't have done there
couldn't have happened to me in New York
City yeah I think Mickey had problems
with it he can't you know country boy
from Oklahoma got in there and you know
you're playing for the Yankees and
you're supposed to be the next Joe
DiMaggio
whereas Willie Willie was didn't have to
follow anybody you know playing for the
New York Giants there but it seemed to
you know it it was good and bad for
Mickey Mantle ya know and I've talked to
Roger Maris before he died he had this
same contrib not because of the people
in New York but because of all the
height that he got when he was chasing
the babes record yeah thank you it's
always great to talk to you I I really
appreciate the time and I meant what I
said growing up I remember the poster of
the 715 homeruns I had on the back of my
door in my bedroom and I remember all
those pitchers so special special moment
whenever we get the opportunity to talk
to you and I want to say it's a special
privilege to me to talk with you I watch
your show
morning I watch it every day and you do
such a marvelous job well thank you said
thank you for very much and anything
that I can ever do please don't hesitate
to call I got my producer gave me a
birthday gift it's the New York Daily
News with your face on it when you hit
your 715 home run and at the top and it
was when it's one of the best presents I
ever got because it's just so simple but
he knows you know what you meant to me
when I was growing up so once again it's
great to have my dad is it's so nice
talking with you and and and may God
bless you thank you you sure your show
is wonderful and I really enjoy it thank
you very very much like the great Hank
Aaron joining us on the program the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience